[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المستشار الالماني بوتين لن يخيفنا وسندعم
اوكرانيا بكل ما اوتينا من قوه وسلاح روسي
خطير يوقفه هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد فما هو
بوتين يستعرض عضلاته الحربيه في يوم النصر
ويبعث برساله للغرب ومجموعه فاجنر ترسل
بهديه للكرملين الكيان الاسرائيلي يعلن عن
هجوم تاريخي مرتقب ضد فلسطين وعرين الاسود
يشمرون عن سواعدهم بانتظار ساعه الصفر عرض
يدخل خط الوساطه في حرب السودان والصين
لكندا هذه بتلك والبادئ اظلم الرئاسه
التركيه تحمل البشرى للشعب التركي وبا
تدخل دوامه الحرب الاهليه
بوتين يحتفل بالنصر
ومع قرع الطبول الحرب لا مانع في الطرف
الاخر ان تقرع طبول الاحتفال نعم سنكسر
قانون الطوارئ وباستعراض عسكري مهين بوتين
ياخذ استراحه محارب ليظهر بعضا من قوه
بلاده المرعبه والهدف ايصال رساله مشفره
ومن الساحه الحمراء وفي قلب العاصمه موسكو
ها هو يحتفل بعيد النصر بمشاركه اكثر من
عشره الاف فرد ومئه وخمسه وعشرين قطعه من
المعدات العسكريه فهنا مدرعات من طراز
تاجر وتايفون ومنظومات صواريخ اس 400
للدفاع الجوي ونقلت جنود المدرعه
وما خفي كان اعظم كان كل هذا الاستعراض
ايها الدب الروسي هناك ايضا جدد بوتين
الاتهاماته للغرب انهم يريدون تدمير روسيا
قائلا العالم يشهد نقطه تحول وموسكو تريد
ان ترى مستقبلا يسوده السلام فعن اي
مستقبل تتحدث واي سلام يا هذا بينما تشكو
اوكرانيا من ضربه روسيه موجعه وتحت كل تلك
الضربات الكثيفه استقبل رئيس اوكرانيا
فولوديست المفوضيه الاوروبيه
فما الذي تحمله هذه الزياره في طياتها هنا
يظهر احد قاده اوروبا ليجيب انه المستشار
الالماني والذي قال ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يجب الا يخاف من القوه الروسيه وان يظل
موحدا لدعم اوكرانيا مضيفا اليوم يستعرض
بوتين صواريخه ودباباته وجنوده انه لا
يخيفنا ونحن سنبقى ثابتين في دعمنا
لاوكرانيا بقدر ما
[موسيقى]
بسياسه والاقتصاد نعود الى الحرب الضاريه
على الارض الاوكرانيه حيث وجدت قوه بوتين
الحل الذي سيعيقه هجوم كييفل مضاد الذي
يجري الاعداد له منذ اشهر ليظهر الروس ما
يجعله بلا جدوى نعم انها القنابل المجنحه
صغيره الحجم رخيصه الثمن هي سلاح قديم
تستخدمه روسيا بشكل فعال لدعم القوه
الجويه دون ان تستخدم ذخيرتها الباهظه
بحسب صحيفه تيليجرام البريطانيه مهلا مهلا
مهلا نحن هنا نسمع صافره انذار نعم انها
صافرات انذار بجانب عده مدن اوكرانيه
تحذيرا من هجمات روسيه اطلقتها القوات
الروسيه على ثاني هجوم من نوعه خلال يومين
ليعلن عمده
تعرضت لاكبر هجوم بطائرات مسيره منذ
اندلاع النزاع ومن هجمات موسكو العنيفه
الى طباخ ب وبعد ان نجحت وصلته بانتقاد
قياده جيش بلاده والتي لم يستبعد
السياسيون والمحللون العسكريون انها كانت
خدعه ماكره اعلن بريغوجي عن بدء تلقي
قواته الذخيره من روسيا واضاف ان قواته
تقدمت لمسافه كبيره في باخموت موديا هذا
النصر لفوتين وذلك احتفالا بعيد النصر
جبهه فلسطين تشتعل هي حرب الماضي والحاضر
هي قضيه العرب الدائمه هي الحرب التي لا
تكاد تهدا قليلا حتى يتم لفظ رمادها ليعود
لهيبها للاشتعال هنا وبعد ان شنت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هجمات هي الاقوى منذ
مده طويله على غزه ونابلس لتولين بعدها
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاده ثلاثه
عشر مواطنا واصابه عشرين اخرين بينهم نساء
واطفال واختناق سبعين شخصا مع اغتي ثلاثه
من القاده العسكريين لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي في غزه ونابلس جراء الغارات
الاسرائيليه على القطاع بينما كانت مجموعه
عرين الاسود ونقصد المقاومه قد نفضت غباره
هدوءها في الضفه الغربيه وردت في كمين
بتفجير عبوه ناسفه في قوه من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ليتم اعطاب 3 اليات عسكريه
اثناء الاقتحام مع اصابات بالغه في صفوف
قوات الاحتلال ليعلن بعدها وزير دفاع
الكيان ان حركه الجهاد اطلقت عشرات
الصواريخ على جنوبي اسرائيل وهذا تحد
لدولتنا بحسب قومه لكن هنا تل ابيب لا
زالت في تخوف من الرد الفلسطيني نتنياهو
يقول انه اعطى التعليمات لوزير الدفاع
والجيش للاستعداد لكل سيناريوهات فما الذي
تعد له المقاومه الفلسطينيه السودان يعاني
الامرين في السودان الحال يرثى له يا ساده
فلما ماء ولا كهرباء والجوع ينخر الجسد
السوداني ولا اعلنت منظمه امميه ارتفاع
عدد القتل المدنيين في الاشتباكات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في السودان الى
640 اشخاص وفرار اكثر من 700 الف شخص بسبب
المعارك وبرغم سريان هدنه بعد اخرى بين
المتحاربين ليتدخل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان شخصيا ويتصل هاتفيا بقائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان في بحث
التطورات في السودان هنا قال بان تركيا
على استعداد لاستضافه مفاوضات شامله
سودانيه سودانيه اذا رغبت الاطراف بذلك
فهل يفعلها هذا العثماني الاحداث
والتطورات
على صعيد الرد بالمثل اعلنت بكين طرد
دبلوماسيه كنديه في رد مماثل على قرار
الحكومه الكنديه بحق مسؤول بقنصليه الصين
في اوتاوا بداعي تدخل في شؤون البلاد وكان
الصين تقول لكندا واحده بواحده فلتحاول
مره اخرى اعلن حاكم مصرف ايران المركز
محمد رضا فرزين ان بلاده ستستضيف مؤتمرا
الشهر المقبل للبحث في ازاله الدولار من
التعاملات الماليه والعمل على اتفاقيه
نقديه متعدده الاطراف اعلن الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان زياده اجور العماله
الحكوميه في البلاد بنسبه
45% اعتبارا من يوليو المقبل مظاهرات
حاشده واحتجاجات جماهيريه واسعه في
باكستان بعد اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق
ورئيس حزب التحريك انصاف المعارض عمران
خان وقوات الامن تشتبك مع المحتجين موسكو
تحتفل بعيد النصر على النازيه في موسكو
وترسل باشاره لاوكرانيا فهل اقتربت
النهايه
[موسيقى]